hi I'm Ali Wong hi I'm Stephen young and
this is the wired auto complete
interview
[Music]
Ellie Wong I feel like they're gonna be
like where does everyone get her glasses
oh yeah
okay where do I get my glasses I love
bar Pereira I get a lot of sunglasses
because I have a huge head and I pop out
the sunglass lenses and then I pop in my
prescription that's my trick how did Ali
Wong
okay I didn't get him I am not with him
so I didn't get him I got him for four
days in San Francisco on a movie that he
was compensated for where is Ellie Wong
okay performing next
okay
Google too I am going on tour this
summer for the first time in a long time
I'm with my new stand-up hour my
favorite venue is the Ryman in Nashville
I think it's the most beautiful venue to
perform in it's my favorite by far yeah
but I also love the Masonic in San
Francisco because it uh is my hometown
why is Ali Wong people on the internet
aren't that nice though always pregnant
hilarious
the reason why I was for my specials for
the first one it was because I was so
reticent to let that hour go but then I
was about to have a baby so that seventh
month was like the last month I could
fly and I was procrastinating I was like
this is the last date I can film my one
hour special before I have a kid there's
all that but you're just like because
she's like a badass working mama oh yeah
yes
second time was because I want to be
fair to the first kid
I'm not always pregnant too that's like
impossible
where did Stephen Young
go to high school I went to Troy High
School shout out Troy Colts and the high
school was designed by a uh like someone
who designs prisons and then you lived
in a prison
yeah
even young got his start I got to do
this show called Walking Dead where I
had no business being there but I got to
be surrounded by incredible incredible
people that taught me so much and I love
all of them and I got to experience
seven years of like every lesson you
could ever be taught in the industry all
at once come on
when did Stephen Young
join The Walking Dead 2010 I was on that
show I just moved to Los Angeles about
five months prior and again forever
grateful who does Steven Yeun
spinal space I play a little kitty cat
named little Caro who has daddy issues
and funny little
does Ali Wong live in San Francisco
no I don't I was born and raised there
but all my best friends from UCLA live
in LA that's really why I can never move
we joke that we're all gonna get a big
house and live together me and my seven
girlfriends oh sick yeah when we
inevitably outlive
everybody because we're all healthy
Asian women yeah it is Ellie Wong
a runner I'm a jogger I'll do like three
miles three to four miles yeah oh wow
because I just jog for uh to listen
basically to 90s r b Spotify stations
it's kind of like how you just sometimes
eat a cracker as a vehicle for the dip
they'll run as a vehicle for SWV did Ali
Wong
write for fresh off the boat I did I
wrote refresh off the boat for three
years that's how I met nanachika Khan
who directed always be my maybe it was a
wonderful experience and taught me so
much about structure and I loved it does
Ali Wong
speak Spanish see where did Ellie Wong
go to college UCLA the University of
caucasians lost among Asians you know I
didn't go to my graduation because of my
last name you know Wong it's like yeah
and I've just been sitting there burning
in the Sun
well
so I was like I'm not gonna go
that's hilarious that's how I met uh all
my girlfriends who are coming to the
premiere okay you've met a couple of
them I love her girlfriends lovely
amazing grounded people and um the
reason why I live in L.A what eating
Steven young yeah we we don't need to
talk about that hey what does Steven
Yeun
look like now you Google it like like
this he's still beautiful he's still
fabulous still has Perfect Skin quaffed
hair the Envy of all all men oh wait no
bumping hairline there's a bunch of Men
Behind camera nodding right now what was
Steven Yeun
nominated for in Oscar yeah for
this wonderfully directed by Lee Isaac
Chung story minari what
happened to Steven young in The Walking
Dead in no in nope he got himself eaten
and it was sad
what happened to Stephen
in general you know what happened I had
two children you know nothing will make
you disappear quicker than two children
[Music]
Ali Wong
quesadilla I don't know moving forward
does Ellie Wong have a podcast no I
don't like to talk for free so even
doing this now is a little bit yeah
you know
Ellie wall
Harley Quinn oh yeah I had a very small
part in uh Birds of Prey directed by
Kathy Ann that's it had a great time I
think I worked there for like a day does
Ellie Wong have a sister I have two who
are very private and will have Choice
words for me if I say anything more than
that why is Ellie Wong
famous is it not obvious I because she's
a yeah
is Steven Yeun
no I'm not vegan what have I done to
make you think that
well thanks but let me tell you we go to
Korean barbecue together every single
month
is Steven Yeun
famous in Korea yeah he's famous
he's also famous in Koreatown do not go
there with him mistake and if you do you
have to make him wear a mask otherwise
it's scary otherwise it turns into a
meet and greet and someone has to take
all the pictures because someone isn't
famous in Korea or Korea Town someone is
not bitter about it
is Steven Young
Robert Pattinson I like me some Robert
Pattinson I got to work with him
recently on a film Mickey 17 and I
cannot talk about it directed it so
that's fun Steven Yan
Invincible voice when I was first doing
that character I tried to make him super
teenage we've now recorded season two
and three his voice gets a little bit
different is that the answer that you're
all over looking for
okay
[Music]